[Music]
this is a perk and I'm gonna teach you
how to dougie now I'm gonna teach you
how to ride the bike we caught up with
ASAP ferg and he taught us some bike
riding basics as well as some advanced
techniques you'll notice that Ferg
isn't wearing a helmet but you
definitely should like this guy first up
let's talk seat height which is ideally
at the hip first you got to make sure
you I see this at the right height
I like the willy you know where my seat
is too low I can't keep the bike up too
long I gotta keep it up a little high so
I could just throw it up long time next
up brakes because before you can ride
you have to know how to stop these are
the two bricks right you have a back
break and you have a front brake front
break on the left back break on the
right sure that'd be nice and hey you
got the adjuster right here just in case
there's a little loose and it works like
this
[Music]
gliding can help you get a feel for
balance here's how it's done
I'm a starch outlaw for something very
simple very easy you take your left foot
and you pedal down give yourself some
motion
and push
now that you've got bouncing down it's
time to pedal I'm gonna teach you guys
how to pedal now it's not hard at all
you'll be like me
[Music]
and then it's all about the flow don't
be scared
let it flow you have to be fearless
don't be afraid to fall off the bike a
little bit sometimes just a flow once
you're confident in your basic skills
you can move on to tricks like the
wheelie actually be like this and you
tap your brakes like this to prevent
yourself from falling back I'm gonna
demonstrate it right now you got to give
yourself some speed see how you tap you
tap tap tap and that's how you Willy a
bike
[Music]
you can catch more fur moves in the
plain Jane music video a little bit I do
that of lausanne house a little scary
gizelle whoo I feel Donegan thank you
[Music]
[Music]